my guest tonight co-starred in the movie
Mean Girls and on such TV shows as
freaks and geeks Party Down and masters
of sex
she was also amazing as Annie Wilkes in
season two of Hulu's Castlerock please
welcome our good friend Lizzy Caplan
Lizzy thank you for doing this it's
really nice of you no problem I had
literally nothing else to do oh that's
right you're in quarantine right and for
some reason are you and a stand-up
comedy club where is this brick wall
coming from is this your apartment
bunker bunker very high blew it I know
I've known you for years and you've
always said I've got to go I'm working
on my quarantine bunker and I always
thought Lizzie what I don't think that's
gonna be a problem who's laughing now
you did it you did it congratulations it
looks beautiful
break my break I built this it's
gorgeous
let me explain to everyone who's
watching right now that you are in
London and so and I want to make that
very clear because just before we
started I forgot for a second that you
were in London and you're in a
completely different time zone it's
evening where you are just before we
started I saw you take a nice sip of
some white wine and I thought oh wait a
minute it's 9:20 in the morning that's
not good and then I realized no what
you're doing is fine the fact that I
just had some white wine at 9:30 in the
morning is a problem so all bets are off
at this point it's forgive yourself do
whatever you need to do to get by and
for the record it's actually an orange
one much room here oh my god it looks
very sophisticated thank you no it's
urine it's it's urine from the bumper
okay so you're in a bunker and you're
drinking your urine that's yeah great
what a lovely way to start the interview
can I just ask you very quickly
I'm just curious I'm experiencing this
in Los Angeles so I have some sense of I
mean ever there's so many different
experiences in America but I have this
feeling that right now in England they
have that famous stiff upper lip as do
you think that's is that true or is that
just a cliche I feel like you'd be much
you guys would be handling it like it's
the Blitz oh it's so a nothing we'll get
through this and people were walking
around with umbrellas and not caring
yeah it's served them the English people
very well during the Blitz and kind of
throughout history I actually but know
it feels a bit like back home I assume
most of us are doing what we're supposed
to do and then there's like a handful of
that feel like they really
need to get out to the park and drink
and public and and cough a lot and
people the ones that are outside without
a mask always coughing yes yeah yeah
we're having that too here in LA they
just opened they're like they didn't
even open the beaches and people just
decided tens of thousands of people said
yeah this isn't cool anymore it was kind
of cool to being quarantined for bit but
I'm bored with it now we're all going to
the beach and we're gonna lick each
other I know I know it's really it makes
me very mad I've become I'm definitely
like following the rules in a really
hardcore way which is kind of a new
thing for me but I don't want to do this
for two years
so just don't go to the beach like it's
not that bad if you're not a health
worker or an essential worker of any
kind like it's not that bad just stay in
your house watch TV or else we're gonna
be doing this forever yeah by the way I
consider myself an essential worker I
need to you know I mean they say
comedies the best medicine I've seen no
proof of that it's actually it's a
terrible medicine how are you handling
you know first of all I want to also
mention give people a little peek behind
the scenes I was in London on business
not that long ago before this pandemic
it and
you and your husband Tom and I got
together we met in a pub and it was a
great I had a great time it was really
it was fun and the highlight was you
ordered something called a scotch egg
and so we're sitting in a pub and we all
have our beers I had a Guinness coz I
was like I'm gonna have a Guinness and
put some hair on my chest again and you
ordered a scotch egg which sounded like
the most disgusting thing in the world
and then actually looked amazing oh now
you say it looked amazing you talked so
much trash about that scotch egg when it
was in front of you you wouldn't touch
it you wouldn't even look at it because
it sounded it's an egg will you tell us
what it is it's an egg it's like a
Russian nesting doll of a snack so it's
an egg surrounded by ground-up sausage
meat or sausage mince as we say here in
England and then breaded and then
deep-fried it's a perfect snack
incredible so the British are geniuses
or this I don't know if it's the
Scottish or whoever they'll take an egg
something that already is high in
cholesterol and then they'll add sausage
to it and then they'll deep-fry it
delicious protein bomb they're geniuses
all right oh it's worth mentioning that
I was very impressed by I appreciate
that you said you had a Guinness but the
sheer volume of Guinness that you took
tout that afternoon was some indivisible
it has no effect on me it goes straight
to my hair and my feet I think I was
steady as a rock
he won't sloppy nope nope I don't get
sloppy beer to me isn't even I mean
Guinness is not alcohol to me it's
pumpernickel bread if somebody put into
a blender and then left in the Sun for
like a year that's what I don't know how
much you love that pumpernickel bread
okay so I'm curious how are you
day-to-day handling this pandemic is
quarantine are you going crazy no
clothes I mean obviously it's worth
mentioning that this is it's a very
weird time with so much worry if you let
yourself really worry about your loved
ones in the state of the world in the
future then it's very very overwhelming
but as far as like my little slice of
quarantine it's really fine I enjoy my
husband I get a kick out of him we don't
have kids so we don't have to like
educate them this is a great time to not
have kids again who's laughing now
exactly it's really not it's not
terrible I kind of also feel like I've
been kind of like training for this my
whole life yeah yeah I'm not totally
quite lazy yes it's but normally like
when this isn't a global pandemic if I
have a lazy day and work hard and then
I'm very lazy when I'm not working and I
find that when I have like a normal lazy
no pandemic day its coupled with this
like horrific inner monologue that I
need to be doing more and accomplishing
more and I'm a loser I wasted the day
tomorrow's gonna be different and now I
haven't even lazier day and it's just
gone
radical self-acceptance anything goes
now this is gonna sound like a creepy
question but what are you wearing that's
what I like to like Dana I'm not doing
that I know I text you sometimes and say
what are you wearing that's a different
whole thing often it's whatever yeah not
to be discussed not to be discussed on
air but what are you like are you
someone that gets dressed up I have
found I'd make an attempt every now and
then to put on like to dress like I've
got to go out in the world but then I
don't go out in the world I try that but
then I fall right back to elastic
waistbands yeah
t-shirts yes yes I
I feel like I'm in like a sci-fi space
movie
it's my favorite part of the day because
I take off my sweat suit I take a shower
and then I put on a clean sweat suit and
that's like the beginning of every
sci-fi go and do their rounds yeah and
then they realize the computer is
smarter than they are and it's taking
away their oxygen where everything goes
wrong they're just putting on their
sweat suits and walk around the
spaceship are you learning anything like
I'm learning things about my neighbors
because I'm usually gone during the day
but now I'm learning you know I can hear
people talking I
I sometimes witness things are you
experiencing that at all
yes definitely my I definitely think
that I've become you know how every
neighborhood has like a creepy woman
that just stares out the window all day
[Laughter]
yeah good yeah oh yeah my favorite my
favorite show currently is looking out
the window across the street and there's
this I haven't actually seen the
neighbor her name is Celia I know this
because there's another young woman that
comes by about once a week to scream at
Celia and it goes on I mean for like 45
minutes she's really serious Celia come
out of the house yeah I mean like the
vocal work is impressive she's great
it's so loud and then she'll like say
her piece and storm off and then she'll
come back cuz she remembered another
thing I don't know what it's about my
know it began because the girl was
pissed about something Celia did to her
mother because the episode one was like
and it goes on I love it and weird
because I'm genuinely like I don't like
to see people fight I don't I don't love
violence but it's gotten to a point
where all I want is for Celia to come
out of the house and for them to fight
each other industry you're invested in
this drama you've put in the time and
now we need to get to like the big act
to moment where we finally listen Celia
now I have a theory
I am theory because this is where my
mind goes the woman on the street
murdered Celia a while ago hear me out
okay cover up for it she goes and the
body's up there to cover up for it she
goes every day knowing that you're
watching to say Celia come out why don't
you come out
that's her alibi you are her alibi and I
would testify that Celia is definitely
in there when you educated me on the
facts I would have absolutely stood in
front of a judge and said there's no
chance that's not enough yeah yeah I'm
telling you or she is in there but she's
in the wall right this is a murder case
you should call the police immediately
before the woman on the street sees this
and then comes after you that's where
the movie goes next I think that's a
great idea I'm gonna start calling the
police every hour something you have
great lighting right now my ears is
glowing nobody it's sort of it's like
one of those Dutch paintings from the
17th century where definitely there's
gentle light coming across your face
very beautiful and then this yeah the
ears a little hot but it almost looks
like that's where the Spirit of God is
coming in you know all right and the
Dutch painters they love to play with
lights yeah so there you go I think you
know no complaint and I love the I love
the electrical pipe that's running down
the side thank you
shimmy up this to get above ground I
should show you my gun rack oh okay well
we'll see that in a minute and your
canned piece that you have all my
neighbors taking at all because one
thing I didn't do was just oh you've got
a lot of guns and no food yeah
all right well how's your family doing
house I mean you keeping in touch with
them yes
don't you find talking so much more to
family everybody's fine my father
definitely thinks that this whole thing
is happening more to him than to anybody
else in the world right heartless for
him even though he's fine he's bored
yeah yeah it's a joy to hear those daily
complaints and but yeah he's fine and
then I like juxtapose that with my
mother-in-law here in England right and
she's actually handling it really
beautifully she's like taking a moment
just absorb this slowing pace and she
sends very long text messages to us a
lot every day saying like I was in the
garden normally I would did it we didn't
feed treatment but I find with all this
extra time I've been hand weeding the
garden he took me back to being a girl
watching my mum with a very sharp knife
taking out all the weeds maybe this is a
time for us all to slow down I love my
children so much that's something you
would read on the back of like a tea bag
you know a really good British tea you
know very inspiring she's doing it see I
told you the British I think are they've
been through a lot and they're there I
think they're you know very adept at
this kind of thing they know what
they're great I mean the Bliss really
was no joke well I would but I'm reading
a book right now by Erik Larsen that I
I know that my proofs is gonna cut this
part out whenever I try to show that I
do like to read a book but just for you
personally uh Eric Larson the splendid
and the vile the splendid in the bottle
splendid by he's one of my favorite
writers and he's written this book and
it is absolutely like you won't want to
put it down you want it you want to keep
going it's just gorgeous
it's a gorgeous it's just about one year
from when he becomes Prime Minister till
pretty much the end of the worst of the
Blitz so I will read that I do find all
of that stuff pretty fascinating
although I do think that it's kind of
hard to read a book these days which is
weird because you even think it would be
I mean it doesn't sound like it is for
you but finding it very hard to
concentrate on things that aren't yeah
yeah don't read can lose the plague I'm
gonna talk about your dog now you said
you you act like it's very carefree you
and your husband no kids but you do have
a dog to take care of it's true satyr by
the minute
what's your dog's name her name is buns
buns okay his buns distracting you at
all during this time of whoa she is
obviously an angel dog she's perfect in
every way she is really acclimated to
this new life where she doesn't go out
as much and walk as much and uh since I
have no acting thing to promote pretty
much the most exciting thing that
happened this week was I I put a rice
cake on on buns his head and I realized
she looked exactly like the character
Yankee from the show on Orthodox
I saw this here in here his buns with
the rice cake on his head and there had
her head sorry here's the side by side
with yong-ki and this is impressive that
was eating a rice cake it's really tight
two images together that is quite
honestly the most exciting thing that
has happened in this house you know what
I've loved that I loved that over the
years I've interviewed you for all these
really big movies shows and you've
always got this big thing to promote and
I love that this is a special time we're
in where it's okay Lizzy let's get to
the promotion you're like all right
my dog buns looks like Yankee from the
show unorthodox with the rice cake which
is shocking because only when you put
the rice cake
[Laughter]
gigi hadid yeah I know but I just I just
just it's a very special time we're
never gonna get to do that again
where I where I end a segment by by
saying make sure you check out Lizzy's
dog buns with a rice cake on her head as
Yankee from unorthodox don't you think I
this is gonna stick in my mind at least
a long now I have a question I've talked
I let me be honest with you I've talked
to some people that look absolutely they
look absolutely dreadful the guys are
really letting themselves go in general
the women are doing a much better job
you look fantastic
what are you doing to take care of
yourself I mean I'm talking about like
self care you know moisturizing doing
things at home now that we can't go out
you you can't yeah moisturizing why
would you waste your Easter lotions
I haven't moisturized once in my life
until I weigh into quarantine and then
that's all I've got
I'm just you know sleeping ten hours a
night which is fantastic I haven't been
I haven't been doing my I really need a
haircut I really need
haircut her I didn't think wait what was
this okay I'm gonna have the editors
look back at that so you wait you looked
fine until you started to push it
forward well I had bangs see before this
started and now they clearly grown out
and Tom my husband is too scared to cut
them because he's afraid that I'll get
mad at him so then I thought hey Conan
seems to know a lot about hair nah maybe
he could help me out with cutting my I
mean really I feel like you probably
think more about hair than that than the
average Joe I think more about hair than
the average hairstylist lots of work has
gone into this over the years
it's your trademark that means
automatically like there's I would trust
you Kate Middleton timet a shallow mate
those are the two primarily known for
their beautiful hair yes thank you it's
nice to be in that elite group by the
way the only way I can make my daughter
laugh now is when we watch a movie with
Timothy sha'lame whenever he walks on
screen I go
and she laughs that's the only thing
I've ever done that she finds funny no I
don't think you should be messing with
your hair your hair looks good coming I
just think like I'm not going back to
work anytime soon
we have at least a couple months I would
like to have a cute fringe as they say
over here help me do it okay how would I
do that would you have any instruments
with you if you have Clippers Clippers
yeah hedge clippers you could get it you
would one chop
no Clippers makes me a little nervous
that's for the short a man's hair or a
short haircuts but no I have um
made this this charity thing this
beautiful rainbow these scissors like
really they were truly just right here
on this rainbow they're obviously for
paper I don't think they're for hair but
they seem fairly sturdy and I trust you
I'm gonna say I've done some scary
things in my career I've never been more
frightened you're a very attractive
woman and the idea of me over a zoom
line here in LA cutting your hair with
not even the right scissors is is
horrifying to me
I don't want scissors make it less
horrifying oh there's no way it would be
less horrifying layers oh I think you
have to keep it that way right there and
then do us it well hold on if you want
the right you know what like keep it
like that and then you have to do but
you have one strand that's much longer
than the other okay okay okay I get rid
of it we're gonna layer it we're gonna
layer it we're gonna do see that strand
right there yeah just cut a little off
of that strand okay like where that's
good no no right there just cut that off
okay then mail that to me and don't ask
why hold on you want the bangs trim you
want the straight-across you're not
gonna believe who are are you willing to
take that whole chunk off right there if
you pull it down right now no bangs I
would like to have my bangs back okay
alright so pull it down past there and
how high do you want them oh my god this
is nerve-wracking this is like talking
someone down who's piloting a 747 that's
what it feels like to me right now
do something up here but I don't know
what so let's just keep going
we're not gonna worry about that alright
hold that right there now do you want it
to be right around where your brows are
I mean
sure if it gets a little shorter I don't
mind a baby bein okay let's do this you
can always take off more but you can
never add someone's home in true
haircutting Pro so start there and just
take off bring your hand down right to
about there and just take off from go up
a little further and from there up there
oh god this scares me so much yeah
go
it's not working is it Oh God
Oh God okay Oh God
Conan it's not bad you know what I have
to say something that is not bad it is
not a minister yeah yeah cuz I'm okay
you'd have to go straight across please
close your eyes no no that's what you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna look
like Moe from the Three Stooges also who
cares stakes couldn't be lower
well no pandemic could end tomorrow and
they could say hey we want you to play
Rapunzel
a big Disney remake and they they say
would but Conan cut my hair from 10,000
miles away okay it's a little low over
the eye over here no no no it's - that's
too much lower there you go right around
there I think go okay yes yeah you do
look like Will Ferrell in Zoolander that
well that's a hole oh yeah that's you
know what you need to do you get get
some shoe polish yeah it's covered in
that part thank you okay a little more
of the eyes just a little more just a
little more this is killing me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah wait I think that really
messed it up
no it's see there's just a little part
that comes down right on the bridge of
your nose it comes down a little far I
don't want to cut my
lots of it now I'm really blind how's it
look you know what it looks good
it looks good I'm all its look I'm gonna
be honest with you I think you look
amazing if you go into a professional
stylist right now
yeah allowed to they would say who did
this to you and there'd be a warrant out
for me
that looks amazing it's like Audrey
Hepburn hair yes no I'm gonna say it's
Roman Holiday you look like like Audrey
Hepburn and Roman Holiday you look you
look gorgeous
now let's do you yeah it's not funny
there's no here I can just pull mine
down you know mine's getting a little
trim I know I know I need a little trim
but I got I got nothing here look at
this oh yes I need that I want to yeah
also the whole envelope yeah I'm a kid
that would come and ask you for a date
who has no shot it's Lizzie here tell
her Conan called and Karl came by and I
just was wondering if maybe she wanted
to go get him malted is that a guy
that's a guy that's a guy dating age I'm
not kidding I like it I think it's
really good I think I just saved your
life and your career
Thank You stubble much I'm telling you
people are gonna see this and they're
gonna be these big deal producers see
let's see this and go that's the look we
always thought of Lizzie as having that
kind of hair but now she's got this hair
and that's perfect
you've opened up so many doors for me
today now for the first time since this
all happened I'm looking forward to
laughter all right well I hope people
out there like it because people really
do love you and
if they don't like what has happened
here
they're going to hate my guts I'm
telling you I thought this was gonna
when I thought maybe code should help me
with my hair I thought it was gonna go
really bad and as it turns out beautiful
yeah well you know me
good at everything let's get exhausted
[Laughter]
so here's I'm gonna we're gonna I I'm
gonna make sure that before we go I
promote once again because please yes
let's get the word out that when buns
has a rice cake on her head like donkey
from from unorthodox yes and you tweet
about that tell your friends oh I'd like
to promote this is called the Conan what
you're wearing right now it's the new
style it's all the rage in London and
I'm gonna get written up in all the
London papers no no I like that it
turned out well I would not I would be
very upset if I marred you in any way so
that would upset me deeply and Nancy
worth whatever comedy gold there was to
be mined I'm a weird guy should we ah
that scares me look that's fear that's
for your husband I want him to be
present when that happens it has been an
absolute delight talking to you as you
know I'm a huge fan of yours
and I love it when we get to just bump
into each other occasionally but today
when I found out yes you're gonna get to
talk to Lizzy Caplan in London that made
my day you're saving me in quarantine so
thank you very very much
thanks in a big way
I'm glad that you are alive that's the
nicest thing you've ever said to me keep
it up
[Laughter]